r
les forces ukrainiennes.
Notre envoyé spéciale Marie-Ève
- C'est devenu un symbole
de la résistanceononononononono.
L'aéroport de Chornobaivka
n're plus qu'un champ
de carcasses de métal tordues
et calcinées, un cimetière
Les Russes ont occupél'l'l'l'at
de la guerre, mais c'est
une occupation qui s'est
Ils y ont séééé
hélicoptères, blindés et
deux généraux dans des attaques
parfois quotidiennes.
"Je suis fier, dit-il,
il le faut. Bien sûr, je ne suit
a subi. C'est un problème.
Il faudra restaurer l'Ukraine.
Mais ce qu'on leur a imposé,
fier. Mon groupe d'amis
et moi avons fait ce que
nous pouvions avec les moyens
Quand Alexander parle
de son groupe d'amis, il pare es
pour la plupart, fidèles
à l'Ukraine et pris au piège
par l'occupation de Kherson,
à leur façon.
"Non seulement, nrorororoupe
est responsable de ça ici,
mais il était également
de transmettre des données sur
l'équipement, sur les mouvements
de l'armée et les positions
de l'armée r L L L L L L L L L ,
alors que les premiers missiles
russes frappaient la capitale
Kiev, Vlad et son père se sont
de recrutement de la défense
terrlelelele pour se porter
volontaires. Mais Kherson
s'est retrouvée encerclées s s t
prendre les armes.
"La défense terrirerererererer.
Nous étions encerclés, dit-il.
Nous avons reçu l'ordre de
nous disperser, parce que
avec des véhicules blindés,
des armes titititiques
et des grenades."
Vlad dit avoir passé quelquesmr
quoi faire pour être utile,
sans pour autant pililililililii
étaient recherchés dans
ce nouveau monde russe.
C'est par des amis qu'il a eu ds
des partisans.
polytechnique. Des soldats
yryryryrov y vivaient,
raconte Vlad. Pendant trois
sur cette rue, j'ai observécet é
à comprendre dans lequel
L'édifice occupé par
les soldats tchétchènes a été
tout juste après qu'il ait
fait son rapport.
Aujourd'hui
fièrement la tenue militaire.
Mais sous papapapation,
il voulait plus que tout
se fai
"Vous dormez et vous rêvez que
les Russes vous pourchassent,
se rappelle Vlad, qu'ils entrent
vous cacher, et à ce moment-là,
vous vous réveillez dans
la nuit au son des moteurs
de leurs camions KamAZ,
de leurs blindés ou des camions
Ural. Et vous sortez der r r r e
à cette r t t t terrible."
Ce cauchemar,
l'a vécu éveillé. Ses activités
clandestines l'ont mené
jusqu'ici en août dernier.
Il n'avait pas encore revu
les murs et les barbelés
de la prison où d
russes lui ont infligé toutes
sortes de châtiments corporels
pendant 17 jours. " " " " " " "t
électrocuté, ils matatatattu
avec leurs bottes et
des matraques sur to
se souvient Alexander.
Ils s'acharnaient suamamamambe,
je ne sais pas pourquoi."
Alexander se décrit
aujourd'hui comme un invalide.
Sa blessure la plus dededede,
c'est en lui qu'il la porte.
Il ne peut s'empêàààààààààààààs
par ici, des familles
ordinaires, parfois.
Surtout, il pense à ceuququququ.
"J'étais loin d'être seul.
Et il y a encore des gens
qui sont détenus, qui n'ont pas
été libérés. Mes collègues,
Ils les ont déplacés ailleurs
dans la région de Kherson,
qu'ils occupent toujours,akakak"
C C C C C C C C C C C C C C C s
o o o o o o o o o o o o o o o s
dans l'une des cel
de détention et de torture
C'est le fils d'Irina,
Sergei, qui lui raconte
avoir froid comme un chien,
Il n'en peut plus.
"Mae-e-e-e-fille a eu 2 ans
le 6 octobre, dit-elle.
C'est le jour ouemmené en Crimé"
Son fils, un militaire
à Kherson. Dès les premières
heures de l'tititition,
Sergei s'est donné pour mission
de soutenir l'effort de krkrkrkd
des secrets.
"C'est sûr que moi,
j'ai essayé de l'arrêter,
dit Sacha. Je l'ai prévenu,
j'ai
pouvait lui arriver."
Sergei a été interrogé
sans relâche par les autorités
russes désormais aux commandes
de Kherson.
Sacha, ses deux filles o o o o,
disent-elles, poteteteter
de subir le même sort.
et son mari se laissaient
de petites notes cachées
da
Irina et Sacha sont
intarissables sur les exploits
militaires de Sergei,
mais ce n'est pas que
par fierté ou orgueil,
c'est aussi par peur.hohohohohot
peur, c'est qu'i t t t traité
comme un civil et que les Russes
liste d'échange de prisonniers,
parce que dans ce cas-ci,
Civil ou militaire,
Sergei evévévévéritable héros,
assurent les deux femmes.
Tous les habitants desesesesesà
la ville, sont aussi des héros.
Ils ont enduré, résisté
et gardé espoi